God of War is a series that has been a
mainstay in my life for the majority of
it ever since picking up the initial
game in 2005 it is constantly set and
met expectations in the industry and
every iteration brings something new to
the table the second in the series
remain my favorite game of all time
until it was knocked off the pedestal by
the seminal The Last of Us so naturally
I was extremely excited when God of War
was announced on the PlayStation 4 upon
picking it up I was instantly hooked by
the personal story of Kratos and his son
Petraeus and their journey through the
Nordic god landscape combat wasn't
rivaled the challenges were cerebral and
there was a real sense of atmosphere and
adventure to the work however upon
completing the game I was disheartened
by the fact that there was no new game
plus mode ever since God of War to you
this has been a motif of the series and
something that was not only essential to
it but also an aspect that added a
wealth of replay value
had it been missing from prior entries
then I may not have bothered to revisit
them and fall head-over-heels as I once
had hit marred an excellent experience
for me and I felt slightly shortchanged
because of it after spending hours
besting the Valkyries upgrading the
shattered gauntlet of Ages and more I
now had nothing to battle my new
trinkets with however there was a
glimmer of hope when rumors began to
surface that the team Santa Monica
studios were working on a new game plus
mode so I waited with bated breath
refusing to start a new game in order to
keep my upgrades until it finally
arrived I'm glad to say that it's now
here and after playing through the main
story of new game plus mode I can say
that the games accused all of the hopes
that I had buried enemies are tougher
faster smarter and stronger and there
still remains a sense of challenge to it
new armors are available as well as new
minerals and tasks that arguably make
this the greatest new game plus mode
ever put out the creators of the game
have really knocked it out of the park
in terms of the depth that they have
added to God of War and one can only
marvel at the fact that they've added in
so many extra elements that even the
most die-hard players may still struggle
with the challenges this new mode brings
players are now able to skip cutscenes
completely so those looking to power
through the game were more than welcome
to however if you've only played through
it once before like myself and I suggest
you take the time out to watch the story
again there are several aspects that
really feel impactful to you to the
added context that the ending brings and
I was blown away by some of the subtext
that is there early on in the story it's
clear that bar log and the team knew
what they were doing and they drop hints
throughout at the overall storyline of
the saga this demands your attention a
second time and he owe it to yourself to
watch through the cutscenes in order to
get a true sense of the narrow
there will be things you miss first time
in the story similar to things you
missed in the actual gameplay
I found myself able to pick up artifacts
I'd missed before open chests that I'd
never even considered attempting and the
new game plus mode adds a wealth of
value to a game that was already
brimming with it it's essential that you
play a new game plus mode if you've
already completed god of war feeling
like the true experience there's balls
to the wall all-out slobberknocker not
only emphasizes the insane combat that
the series is known for but it also
advances the story in many ways the
upgrades that you are able to implement
to your armor feel like an Co of fresh
paint and it really cannot be hammered
home how much this addition enhances the
experience God of War was always a game
boasting a lot of action but this
evolves it in certain necessary ways
that demand your attention and make a
second playthrough required if you are
to consider yourself a true gamer God of
War was already one of the best games I
have ever played but this goes above and
beyond to secure its par the top because
of all of the prior facts I cannot score
the game any lower than a perfect ten
out of ten so have you played through
god of war new game plus mode and if so
what did you think comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and subscribe to my
channel I create content like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of games recently I broke
down the ending of God of War so make
sure you check that video out next
linked at the end of this one again
thanks very much for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]